bientôt vous excuser aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur agger point il y en ait un
qui m'avait conseillé en masse par mail
par twitter par pigeon voyageur même
depuis tout à l'heure je déboule comme
ça passait derrière apparemment je crois
que le but c'est de bouffer les autres
voilà c'est parti playes
alors ok ça joue juste avec la souris il
faut juste bouffer ses petits points là
comme ça et ensuite bouffer les autres
joueurs réputés petit plus tu vas vite
ce qui fait que là on est plus gros
client le bouffe c'est tout con mais
j'avoue que ça al'air tête à des petits
fous own the feeling of arland non ok un
bord au dos il ya un mois à tokyo je
m'en fous j'adore être tout petit et
très rapide par exemple lui nouveux
banamba nantes roland non regardez le
scirpe état il fait 10 fois bataille le
wake non non désolé [ __ ] non tu y
arriveras pas à columbia s'était pas
prévu au il s'est divisée en deux le mec
comment on fait donc je ne me taper tout
un guide juste pour savoir comment se
diviser quoi plus jamais en les normes
actuellement on va défoncer donc au
papier sur espace pour se diviser voilà
et en voyant on peut se cacher là dedans
en fait voilà comme ça nos joueurs ils
ne voient pas en dieu il son être mme
yap hollande que c'est de bouffer
l'autre ces affreuses convoi casse-toi
france casse toi et vas-y me cache je
peux plus je suis trop gros aux france
il est nommé il a bouffé copains il a
bouffé un autre joueur bordel et il veut
te défoncer bien aidé russie doit pas
mais des russes il ya un mec landes qui
te colle au cul proches battant bordel
mais je suis au revoir bosnien oh qu'est
ce que c'est bon mangez un joueur c'est
génial c'est de tout coup comme jeu mais
[ __ ] qu'est ce que c'est addictif
oh non il nous y vient on est dans le
coin j'ai mes fans
il a toutefois raté dans ton cul texane
ou d'excès anou [ __ ] il avait trop de
dextérité
yayou match qui veut bouffer ses
premiers de la game il est divisé fait
déjà tout l'écran le mec sans déconner
oh la la
get a life oui je rage belgique vient là
vient la belgique
vas-y bien 10 victoires en 10 a fait ce
match on absorbe tout j'ai envie de
pleurer
et ben moi j'en sais ça fait du bien
d'aller vite par contre voilà au revoir
à temps le mec gt puis sur son jumeau le
galilée lui a fait la meilleure
croisière du monde sur les connaît et
pour nous lui
oh oh la chance qu'il a eue il a tapé
une estime on défonce vas-y papa mais
[ __ ] c'est pas ça je t'ai demandé papa
je déniche au bâton mais là dans le
mmorpg qui dans des pick-ups hague
sans déconner papapapa du coup il a pris
du bide à au plat ah ben ouais pas bon
être août désolé pour grands je suis
très heureux voilà on a pris quelques
kilos d'un puissant fait plaisir là j'ai
envie de me répéter mais en a raté
du coup je suis ultra vulnérables dans
le conte et comment se reforme avait du
coup c'est pas vrai parce qu'on ramasse
beaucoup plus de points ouais on est
beaucoup plus vulnérable à mes attentes
et je vais m'énerver
il faut vraiment je crois est du style
voilà battant raté tu t'es dit viser
pour rien ok les skis bien lol tous les
avis et elle doit être dégoûté shirt
ample réécouter sellal qui pleure il
faut que je m'en sorte comme ça ok ou
alors là j'ai fait un move de génie
incroyable ce que j'ai à faire je me
suis piqué pour survivre en plus tard
c'est hyper addictif ce jeu c'est
incroyable oups désolé et je pourrais
passer la journée sur ce jeu sans
déconner en vrai c'est une feuille à
petits carreaux sur laquelle il ya des
juges des points de couleur quoi il va
se quitter je suis précipitée
quel [ __ ] nous fait ça deux fois de
suite à la mouche elle est toute petite
elle qui faisait la malle et dans des
bulles partie haute et dagano tu m'auras
jamais nazis mais doux mais bien la
twilight arrive quoi doute eu mon album
il a tenté un truc c'est totalement raté
bien l'asie vient là vient la montgrand
voilà tu voulais baceco comprends ta vie
papa non nazi je te déteste au nom au
mais il fait du puea thaï pourquoi tu
t'attaques à un homme si faible comme
moi au le on assistait à un cri bammer
aut l'avaloir procès tout la phrase est
horrible mais c'est pas parce qu'on
reprend sur de meilleures bases
un jour on sera gros comme lui en
dessous vient là où souvient la bière là
je te dis non la pad jeune homme quand
il est encore plus content d'avoir fait
ça gagne au loto au le boutis la pesca
jeu viendra emmerde je suis donné la
mort qui tue est de retour le grand
autour la tristesse de ce mouvement
quoi j'aurais de pleurer mais j'aime
bien utiliser parce que tu as plus vite
c'est plus agréable quand même un atout
pour le prix d'un au revoir est énorme
on l'affublé souvenez-vous cp machin
portugal là où elle a vu comme ça
peut pas nous manquer de respect à
prayssas sur l'icône et bats-toi dont je
fume soul c'est très violent et année
dont il veut se venger c'est drôle à ces
vignes ont tenté à nous au revoir à au
portugal il s'est fait défoncer on va
par le bouffer hondurienne arrière assez
incroyable vous avez dit que vous allez
faire un final exceptionnel j'en étais
sûr on est totalement énorme et du coup
on bouge à deux à l'heure c'est énervant
venez là bien là piccolo non non je me
suis retrouvé à sa maturité
regardez du coup l'udc hindou suis hissé
ô pays bien bien bien bien bien là bien
là non lucas il a tout gagné
non il va se diviser non ok ok voilà on
est retour la poussière ok on a pris un
petit peu de bidons là on va pouvoir se
débrouiller un peu avec ça bouge pas et
je me dis vise en rien le piège c'est
eux divisés à mon avis à fois que le
contre exemple mon dieu d'ange qui a
grandi tu devenu un gros chien chien
allait heureusement j'avais ça a raté
bien hâte à 10 coups de la vie d'un dico
la meilleure note à dix couleurs fait-il
énorme
j'ai mangé un petit bout mais le lan fei
avait le gros coup derrière quoi c'est
comme s'ils tombent était le fils du
papa qui fait 200 kg et que du muscle
c'est quand je me rends forme maintenant
lequel question où la bouffe et là on
est bien là on peut finir sur samassa
voire deux pour un toit c'était meilleur
coup notre ville à quoi pourquoi
mais non et l'autre qui vient et qui se
rassasie staut est mortelle il vient là
bien voilà voilà d'où tu touches mais
petit bébé à moi je t'adore aujac non
non non non aux mavs à la fois de cette
vidéo sur agger boyau c'est hyper
amusions à merci mais on fait découvrir
ce truc c'est tout con mais vraiment
amusant j'espère sera plus ces cas
n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo comme
d'habitude et puis on se retrouve très
bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo voilà
retire tout le monde le pis tu fais du
sport quand un oui quand vous avez un
au fc bakou